[Musique]
notre ca du mercredi avec diane et
nicolas bonsoir bonsoir on va parler
d'abord on a quelques sujets qu'on va
aborder ce soir maison des aînés selon
nos collègues daniel boily et thomas
gerbet de radio canada les appels
d'offres pour cette maison des aînés ont
été annulés l'été dernier parce que les
propositions reçues étaient jugés trop
élevés or les nouvelles soumissions sont
finalement jusqu'à 18% plus haut de 44
millions de dollars de plus finalement à
payer pour le gouvernement c'est la
faute à l'inflation nous dit-on la
pénurie de matériaux et la ias 34 des 46
maisons prévues qui sont déjà en
chantier et les oppositions demande
qu'on abandonne les les chantiers
suivants le temps que les prix se
stabilisent ou pour voir un peu plus
clair diane d'abord qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez mais je pense que c'est une
pause et très secret très salutaire pour
deux raisons pour des raisons
inflationnaire mais aussi parce que la
trajectoire que prend l'hébergement pour
aînés au québec est un peu préoccupantes
donc deux côtés on veut investir
massivement dans des résidences pour
aînés qui vont être le nec plus ultra du
bonheur mais de l'autre côté on finance
massivement les résidences privées pour
aînés à travers toutes les crédits
d'impôts qui sont accordés il faut
savoir que le fameux crédit d'impôt pour
maintien à domicile 80 % de la deûle
enveloppe de 21 selon la chercheure amie
anne claude denis risse devra aller où
résident des rpa ça veut dire que ça ça
représente 80% en plus de la somme des
crédits d'impôts donc à des crédits
d'impôt de médecins domicile donc d'un
côté le gouvernement dit j'ai pas assez
d'argent boîte que ça coûte très cher
ces maisons pour unique mais peut-être
qu'il est un peu plus d'argent s'il fit
danser - le réseau privé mon ami fou
comme faire un choix donc je pense qu'il
ya peut-être une réflexion s'impose
votre réflexion avoue nicolas
même message ça me fait sourire qu'on
est surpris qu'un dépassement de coûts
dans un projet gouvernemental c'est un
peu comme si on était surpris qu'en
janvier au québec il ya de la neige et
qui fatigue on aimerait y revenir et
ineo com ou est un peu quand même un peu
réaliste ou sinon c'est très important
d'abord de regarder le budget 1 il est
des pas il dépasse pourquoi est ce que
c'est vrai que l'inflation serre puisque
c'est vrai qu'il ya une pénurie pour des
matériaux de construction et une rouge
de prix aussi des matériaux de
consommation ayant une pénurie pour des
employés dans le monde la construction
donc effectivement ça peut être 100 % en
raison ça cependant comme dans tout
projet dans le budget il devait avoir un
plan de contingence devait avoir un
budget mis de côté pour pour vérifier au
cas où on pouvait avoir des risques
potentiels ce qui est arrivé donc ça me
surprend quand même un peu là que ça
explose quand même 18% de plus c'est
quand même beaucoup après pour vouloir
mettre de côté arrêté et puis on
abandonne le projet attention pas sans
tensions parce que là quand est-ce qu'il
va repartir le projet attention mais je
veux juste pas qu'on mette toujours tout
sur le dos de l'inflation et de tout ce
qui se passe pour messi c'est vrai que
c'est pour ces raisons là bas 6 1%
compréhensible yelle hausses de coûts
dans toute notre vie donc inclure dans
la construction le dernier budget du
gouvernement du québec prévoit 145
millions de dollars de plus pour les
soins à domicile pour un budget total de
2 milliards 900 millions de dollars il
ya les maisons des années il ya les
soins à domicile les deux sont
importants mais ce quart d'heure qui
plus prioritaire si je peux dire comme
sodium mais à mon avis les soins à
domicile sont prioritaires parce que
maintenir les années dans leur milieu de
vie le plus longtemps possible ceux qui
veulent évidemment ça fait des années
qu'ils sont plus en santé plus longtemps
qu'ils sont en meilleure santé morale en
meilleure santé psychologique donc c'est
clair que des soins à domicile de
qualité donné par des gens qui sont
qualifiés qui ont le temps de faire les
choses c'est une priorité dans une
société vieillissante
on travaille en amont donc travailler en
aval d'un de payer pour des soins à
l'hôpital ou payer pour des soins plus
l'eau dans des résidences ouais nicolas
mais effectivement je suis 100% d'accord
cependant je ferai attention à 2,2
points longs et les yeux loin du coeur
souvent si on voit pas le patient
j'espère que l'on va tout faire pour
s'assurer qu'elle a même qualité de
soins premièrement et deuxièmement
j'espère aussi qu'on va investir
massivement pour les prochainement il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui aimeraient
idée qui ne peuvent pas aider pour mille
et une raisons il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui aimeraient accueillir leur
parent ou quelqu'un de malade dans la
famille chez eux le métis et les
investissements massifs donc sincèrement
l'important c'est de s'assurer de la
qualité des soins deuxième sujet les
bonis 600 employés de la société des
alcools du québec jean ce partage et 9
millions de dollars pour avoir atteint
tous les objectifs
il n'y a pas de bonis pour la haute
direction de loto québec mais a quand
même 2300 salariés qui sont éligibles à
des bonis totalisant de 4,5 millions de
dollars petit échanges en chambre ce
matin à québec
le nom du premier ministre de mettre fin
aux portes et des bonis dans les
directions de nos sociétés d'état
c'est indécent et sa droite celle ci
c'est vrai que dans certains codes
société d'état je préférerais qu'on
élimine éventuellement les bonis partons
on est dans une société de droit quand
un dirigeant signe un contrat où il est
prévu dans son contrat d'emploi que des
bonis on peut pas du jour au lendemain
médecins aux poubelles
nicolas est ce qu'un parti de bonis dans
les sociétés d'état ce qu'il faut
changer ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez
y avait rien à nos devoirs c'est un
excellent parlementaire il faut lui
donner mais des fois il fait de la
politique que je déteste il le le terme
importer des bonnes il a tout sauf un le
journal la hune journal cependant ça
fait partie d'une structure salariale
bien normal d'avoir des bonis en place
parce que de toute manière si on ne veut
pas des bonniers à la fin d'année bon
ben ok on va lui couper puis on va
offrir un meilleur salaire si c'est
blanc bonnet bonnet blanc un moment
donné chaque personnel droite si les
objectifs sont atteints ici sont même
dépassés on l'espère dans une société
d'état parce que l'argent ne revient à
la fin ben ils ont le droit de repas
repartager la plus value qui l'ont amené
je vois aucun problème avec ça
franchement le bonus est souvent reliés
à la performance
fusionneront la performance pour une
fois qu'on donne pas des médailles à
tout le monde vient mais le surnomme a
pas d'accord avec nicolas alors
le boni est complètement dénaturer alors
quand on travaille une relation
contractuelle avec un employeur donc je
suis payé pour faire une tâche si je
fais mieux que ma tâche je mérite un bon
humains bonus est une circonstance ça
devrait dans des circonstances
exceptionnelles
quand par exemple je suis j'ai dépassé
les objectifs quand je suis j'ai tenu le
fort pendant une période difficile je
suis venu en aide à un collègue que j'ai
trouvé une idée royal et tous les jeunes
à la saq et loto-québec ne touchent pas
des bonis pour les raisons que vous
décrivez dionne et ça c'est mon point
c'est que les bonis sont souvent liés à
des raisons financières et objectifs
financiers alors moi j'ai juste une
question pour nicolas nicolas directeur
de département qui dépasse ses objectifs
financiers mais dont le taux de benoît
et le taux de roulement est plus élevé
que dans tous les autres départements va
voir son boni pareil parce que dépassé
ses objectifs financiers donc c'est pour
ça qu'elle est bonne et en soit c'est
hors de question réponse nicolas et bien
j'ai la réponse parfaite parce que non
il leur a pas parce que dans la
structure salariale dans le boni il ya
aussi cette réalité prises en
conséquence le boeny des concurrents de
penser au capital et celle que gros
cigare qui veut écraser tout le monde
était chaud son crocodile le boni si
c'est vraiment une manière de motiver
les troupes de remercier les trop et tu
te faire en sorte d'oeuvre une cystine
rue et le le surplus qui a été fait
effectivement c'est pas toutes les
entreprises qui prennent en compte la
santé mentale la stratégie de m parmi
les meilleurs dans l'instruction de
limon parce que c'est pas toutes les
entreprises qui le font qu'il faut dire
que toutes les entreprises ne font pas
pourquoi c'est si sensible cette
question là nicolas
c'est un tabou québec faire de l'argent
ou même à l'argent c'est un tabou et
donc c'est normal moi ça me fait rire
quand on voit 6,3 millions on saute aux
clôtures pour monsieur et mon com comme
salaire et et bonnier et et autres camps
réunies ce mignon pour eux se salir la
pour eu pour un pdg d'une institution
financière de cette grandeur il doit
faire dix fois plus violent écoutez moi
chez les jeunes la huitième cas lundi
que c'est moi qui ai lénine et rose mais
dans ce cas ci c'est lui calé je pense
que le nombre d'entreprises qui lie les
bonis à des objectifs extra financiers
sont très rares et c'est ça qui est
choquant c'est que les bonis sont liées
des objectifs financiers il n'y a pas
d'objectif extra-financiers considérer
les dommages collatéraux sont pas
considérés si on atteint nos chiffres de
ventes si on atteint notre notre cible
si ce qui se passe alors cette fois ci
nicolas c'est pas moins qu'elle est une
étrange
mais j'ai peut-être les lunettes roses
mais sur le plancher des vaches c'est
comme ça que ça se passe souvent mais
effectivement il ya des excès là je suis
pas fou non plus mais attention de
toujours tiric de chouettes vouloir plus
catholique que le pape pie toujours
dénoncé le parti des fautes mais le
bonheur si hockey quand j'avais 18 ans
départ yosa rage avait poliment semaine
whisky mais qu'elle maintenait non c'est
ok belichick parfait on va s'arrêter là
ziti formidable merci à vous deux bonnes
soirées la semaine prochaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit